the former vice president sounded
confident when he spoke to chief
Washington correspondent major Garrett
right after the debate you're gonna win
I'm gonna win shocked by how much I
don't know what does it matter I think
it's just important that I win
just letting point is enough one point
is enough but I think I run by a lot
more than that look the African American
he knows me my record they know me for
the last 40 years I've kept my word I've
done everything I've said major Garrett
is with us now from Charleston good
morning to you major late night for you
to listen morning good morning okay much
so good morning the vice president
refuses to entertain any conversation
that he won't win do you think the
debate last night I know going into it a
lot of people said they had not made up
their minds what are you hearing this
morning for Vice President Biden well
his camp feels very good about the night
and afterwards before we had a chance to
talk on the center stage there were so
many people who came up and wanted to
shake the vice president's hands that's
not uncommon after debates but here in
South Carolina I asked him I said what
are they telling you he said they felt
like we really did what we needed to do
last night and so there's nothing in
terms of momentum or what Joe Biden has
always had in South Carolina the
dissipated last night in fact it may
have been strengthened considerably by
his performance and it is as the vice
president said crucial for him to win
and one point for him will be enough I
don't think that's going to be true for
the long arc of this campaign but a
victory is a victory Joe Biden hasn't
had any he's had a lot of distant fourth
fifth seconds he needs a victory here
he feels like last night got him closer
everybody pointed pointed their attacks
at Bernie Sanders last night major do
you think that made a significant
difference how did Sanders do after the
debate talking to mayor Pete
buddha-heads the Vice President and
others they said look senator Sanders is
the undisputed frontrunner but he is not
vetted his record in the Senate is not
known to the American public they're not
evaluating yet as a potential president
let alone nominee and that process needs
to accelerate it began last night in
earnest lots of attacks on the Senators
legislative record some of his rhetoric
about other countries we heard
references to cuba nicaragua etc whether
or not the Senators record is vetted or
not
we'll be after voters here in South
Carolina obviously politicians who say
the front runner isn't vetted are trying
to serve themselves what voters here
will suggest on Saturday and give a
signal to Super Tuesday States is do
they want to take a second deeper look
at senator Sanders or do they want to
run with the momentum he is successfully
built until this point in the campaign
major senator Warren her performance
rated favorably in the CBS poll but that
has not translated to overall poll
support do you think she broke the
streak last night and may see a balance
as a result of her performance so what's
fascinating about Senator Warren's
entire approach to last two debates in
the last two weeks has been to do two
things one if she's going to attack she
first attacks Mike Bloomberg and if she
says some things about senator Sanders
there hey progressives are good
progressive is right he's on the right
track I'm just a better alternative what
does that tell us that tells us that
Senator Warren also believes there's
something about senator Sanders that's
not going to last that because he hasn't
been vetted he's gonna fall and she
wants to be the progressive alternative
and at the same time make sure helpful
to Sanders but also possibly helpful to
her keep Michael Bloomberg and his
millions and millions of dollars at bay
that's a fascinating strategy I'm not
sure it's going to work but it is the
one she has played now consecutively in
two straight debates that tells you
that's the one she's going to stick with
all right we'll see what works major
thank you very much